alors il n'y aurait pas de nécessité de
réformer le système de retraite s'il y
avait pas une problématique de
démographie là où dans les années 70 il
y avait quatre actifs par retraités il y
en a aujourd'hui 1,7 si on aura dans
quelques années plus que 1,5 donc ce qui
crée mécaniquement un problème de
déséquilibre financier budgétaire du
système de retraite c'est la raison pour
laquelle la réforme nous apparaît
nécessaire ce que nous voulons proposer
c'est un contrat social c'est un contrat
sociétal avec les entreprises avec les
partenaires sociaux de façon à ce qu'on
puisse résoudre ce problème de taux
d'emploi des seigneurs qui va participer
aussi à l'équilibre financier des
régimes de retraite le taux d'emploi des
seniors en France est inférieur à la
moyenne européenne il est 16 points
inférieurs auto en Allemagne clairement
c'est totalement insatisfaisant et c'est
la raison pour laquelle le groupe modem
à l'Assemblée nationale propose un
système de modulation des cotisations
des entreprises en fonction du taux des
seniors ni plus ni moins qu'un bonus
malus sur le même principe que les
contrats courts c'est un système qui
fonctionne parfaitement la réforme des
retraites va permettre d'avancer sur la
question de la pénibilité du travail sur
la question du taux d'emploi des seniors
sur la une meilleure prise en compte de
la pénibilité
et puis une prise en compte également
des carrières hachées qui touchent
notamment les femmes alors une autre de
nos propositions c'est une meilleure
prise en compte de la maternité des
femmes lorsque les femmes ont eu des
enfants elle se heurtent souvent à un
problème de carrière haché qui arrivait
au moment des retraites les pénalistes
très fortement dans le niveau des
pensions donc nous proposons des
trimestres supplémentaires pour les
femmes clairement les débats
parlementaires sont pas au niveau de
l'importance de la réforme l'obstruction
recherché par la nups par lshi et
absolument scandaleuse elle nuit au
débat parlementaire elle va nous
empêcher de traiter d'un certain nombre
de sujets elle va par exemple nous
empêcher de prêter la pénibilité c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous leur
demandons de retirer un certain nombre
de leurs amendements de façon à pouvoir
aborder ces sujets dans l'hémicycle le
débat c'est dans l'hémicycle ce n'est
pas dans la rue